et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
franck louvrier mer et l'air de nabeul
conseiller politique de valérie pécresse
candidate à la présidentielle 2022
bonsoir et merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau pierre cabaret
député la république en marge de la
haute-garonne merci à vous pierre un
cabaret d'être avec nous et bonsoir et
parce qu'il peyton dussault ses
conseillers ères est non en
ile-de-france bonsoir à vous également
jean-michel leblanc caire qui a donc
fait amende honorable assemblée
nationale surtout sur le choix de la
destination l'île voilà qui est réputé
plutôt pour pour sa fête et ses
excentricités je reconnais une
symbolique je la regrette at il dit
c'était maladroit ou c'est une faute
politique pierre cabaret
c'est un choix c'est un choix de lieux
de vacances alors j'entends bien que on
aurait sûrement en tant que français
préféré qu'il passe ses vacances à la
baule mais sap a été son choix donc il
est vrai vous le regrettez oui
écoutez dont je crois que il faut pas
faire une affaire d'une chose pareille
un lieu de vacances cette année de
vacances un choix c'est un choix
d'ailleurs il reste dans un choix tout à
fait logique puisqu'il est à moins de
deux heures de paris et s'y est
disponible puisque la preuve il a été
interviewé mais je crois que en pleine
pandémie on a besoin d'autre chose comme
comme sujet et surtout sur l'éducation
moi je préférais su parler d'un sujet
comme l'orientation pour dans
l'éducation l'orientation des enfants
des élèves qui on va pas faire 80 % de
bacheliers moi c'est mon dada vous savez
l'orientation et vrd des des études
courtes pour pouvoir orienter les jeunes
vers des métiers et des métiers où il se
réalise c'est vrai que il faut pas être
naïf c'était la veille un de la rentrée
scolaire un protocole sanitaire qui est
arrivés très tardivement dans la soirée
certains pains par en ont fait
l'expérience de lundi matin à 8 heures
je vous le confirme francs que l'ouvrier
le général de gaulle avait raison au
ministre va ça passe ses vacances en
bretagne et c'est tout malheureusement
je touche tant qu'il est assez amateur
de près ce qu'on fait n'est plus aussi
de retour à des choix des générateurs de
l'île de bréhat donc juste ou non mais
au delà de l'as de la forme et du fond
la difficulté si vous voulez c'est que
symboles et les efforts et il présidera
ensuite le c'est bien parce qu'il fait
des manifestations aussi à forte
connotation symbolique et le fêtait ses
15 ministres
malheureusement pour lui d'abord quand
il est muni de la république française
c'est bien qu'ils aillent en france pour
la simple et bonne raison c'est que nous
sommes la première destination au monde
et que lorsque vous représentez la
république eh bien vous allez en france
peut-être ça dure que quelques
pas sûr qu'il ait retrouvé du soleil au
delà de ça je pense que c'est un symbole
qui est important et puis derrière tout
ça qu'est-ce que ça traduit parce
qu'enfin monde se sont pas les hommes
politiques que les femmes politiques qui
ont réagi les premiers ce sont notamment
les agents de l'éducation nationale ils
ont été très choqués parce que derrière
ça traduit une forme de désordre de
désordres qu'a eu sur ce protocole qui a
été annoncé au dernier moment dans la
presse sans être
informée et on informer les enseignants
et donc de ce fait là je pense que au
delà du symbole qui est fort il ya aussi
derrière tout ça une désorganisation qui
dure depuis quelque temps notamment dans
l'éducation nationale mais aussi un
autre secteur on l'a vu pour la santé et
donc traduit un énervement une
exaspération des personnes qui
travaillent et qui estime que c'est un
peu la goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder
le vase
et c'est déplorable parce que c'est vrai
que un ministre c'est à la fois un
ministre de la république et donc il
doit à la fois porter le lourd fardeau
du symbole tout en portant bien sûr
aussi lourd fardeau de l'action en tout
cas la majorité a passé sa journée à
défendre son ministre mais quelques
ténors politiques eux sont montés au
créneau c'est le cas de la candidate du
rassemblement national marine le pen est
cotée
enfin cette désinvolture elle dit
quelque chose voyez cette désinvolture
qui consiste à à partir
passer ses vacances dans des endroits
dits paradisiaque
démontre d'abord une forme de désintérêt
pour ce que vivent les français en
pleine campagne présidentielle et le
deuxième enseignement c'est en réalité
on n'est pas confronté à une crise
sanitaire donc on est confronté bien à
volonté politique c'est à dire que ce
qui justifie cette forme d'agitation de
la part du gouvernement en terme de
votes du pass notamment vaccinale et de
multiplication des protocoles n'est pas
une raison sanitaire car si c'était une
raisons sanitaires je suppose que
monsieur blanc caire ne serait pas sur
les plages d'ibiza les doigts de pied en
éventail
étendu sauce et marine le pen a compris
que jean michel blanquer a été un petit
peu devenu le maillon faible du
gouvernement c'est l'homme à battre et
c'est une aubaine finalement pour
l'opposition à trois mois de la
présidentielle et pour marine le pen
notamment
pu écouter ce qui est certain c'est que
ce n'est pas l'opposition qui est
responsable des destinations de vacances
de noël du ministre de l'éducation
nationale les manuels ma course avoir
reçu jean michel blanquer
lorsque ce qui est ce qu'il faut retenir
ce qui est important c'est que comme on
l'a dit la politique c'est l'art est
quand même l'art du symbole sur un
certain nombre de choses évidemment des
actions des décisions à prendre mais il
ya énormément de choses qui se passent
au niveau du symbole et c'est vrai que
quand on président de la république qui
hystérise complètement la crise
sanitaire à des fins politiques tout le
monde aura compris notamment avec ce
pass vaccinale qui est d'une inutilité
mais total énormément de spécialistes le
disent notamment le médecin bernard a
jauni et qui a été à la trentaine il ya
quelques jours et donc si vous voulez
quand on a un président qui nous dit que
finalement c'est la guerre rien ne va
plus on ne contrôle plus rien et qu'au
même moment en effet on a un de ses
ministres et non non par un des moindres
puisque c'est celui de l'éducation
nationale et on sait à quel point la
rentrée a été difficile non seulement
pour les parents d'élèves pour les
élèves mais aussi pour les enseignants
les personnels les établissements
scolaires et bien qui pendant ce moment
là était en train de se détendre
tranquillement à noël évidemment le
symbole il est terrible pour le
gouvernement et on voit bien qu'il ne
prend absolument pas au sérieux les
français dans ce domaine là
match
est vraiment c'est vraiment donc d'abord
il faut quand même un peu revenir sur
terre un des doigts de pied en éventail
abissa moi je connais pas cette île mais
je pense pas qu'à noël on met les pieds
en éventail sur la plage non je crois
que on n'a rien d'autre à proposer que
des polémiques alors ça oui
effectivement les oeufs le lait le front
national n'a aucun autre sujet que la
polémique parce que finalement il n'y a
jamais de propositions quant aux élèves
vous êtes bien ennuyé les nerfs parce
que chaque fois que pécresse propose une
chose mc on l'a déjà vu l impétrant je
vous
madame pécresse oui excusez moi je crois
qu'elle m'en voudra pas non plus non
sélection ça mais aussi dans le nord
mais c'est vrai excusez moi je reconnais
que madame pécresse
effectivement à une une fonction
importante sur la région et quelques
lits des choses importantes sur
l'éducation d'ailleurs puisque la moitié
des deux lycées sont à refaire
actuellement donc je trouve que l'argent
nécessaire il est au delà de toute
polémique donc aujourd'hui on a quoi on
a une polémique sur le masque on aurait
fait mieux quelqu'un peut dire dans huit
jours ce qui peut arriver dans 15 jours
mais dîtes le alors dans ces cas-là
engagez vous mais si vous engagez et ça
réussit pas au moins ayez le
l'honnêteté de le reconnaître
ça c'est important donc on est dans une
période de pandémie
l'économie on n'a jamais lâché l'école
on l'a toujours souhaité la laisser
ouverte c'est la santé c'est vacciner
soigner sauver donc à part ça le reste
de l'opposition c'est toujours
l'opposition il faut absolument peau
limitées sur des sujets franchement que
blanc caire soit à ibiza qu'il roule en
clio ou en toyota qu'il mais quelle
importance au niveau des français quelle
importance je je je comprends pas alors
c'est le symbole faut pas exagérer non
plus le symbole des symboles de la
république
non je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
d'exagération et vous le savez cette
celi effectivement essayé de pousser
quelque chose qui ne vaut pas la peine
quand vous avez fait des oppositions
c'est dix fois mieux mais dix fois mieux
sur le combat laissez répond franck
louvrier sur les propositions m'enfin
pas s'empêcher regardez ce qu'ils
message du député l ère du pas de calais
pierre henri dumont regardez ce qui
n'empêche si jean michel blanquer avez
suivi nos conseils il aurait pu rester
une semaine de plus à ibiza
est candidate
déjà aurait dû monter un petit peu de
tact ambien dire c'était une proposition
il est vrai madame valérie pécresse en
l'occurrence de éventuellement donner la
possibilité de rouvrir une semaine plus
tard ce qui aurait permis peut-être de
mieux s'organiser
et éventuellement de pouvoir avertir au
moins les 20 millions de personnes
concernées par cette rentrée scolaire
qui sépare c'est pas c'est pas rien dans
un pays de pouvoir essayer de gérer ça
au mieux mais au-delà de ça moi je pense
que d'abord la réaction pavlovienne de
la démission systématique n'est pas
utile est vraiment à me font part des
sondés cela ne fait pas avancer les
choses mais la difficulté et le fond du
problème il est très simple c'est que
quand vous êtes ministre de la
république vous fêtez vos gestes sont
très importants bien sûr que vos actes
et vos propositions sont essentielles
sur x men mais quand vous êtes à 83
jours du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous avez comme devoir
bien sûr comme quand vous êtes ministre
surtout quand voulait depuis cinq ans
parce qu'en l'occurrence on peut pas
dire que monsieur bancaire et du nouveau
monde il a eu une expérience auparavant
et il avait cette expérience pendant
cinq ans il faut prendre en compte
toutes les émotions du pays est
aujourd'hui la simple attitude qui doit
avoir c'est de dire qu'il a fait une
erreur et puis et puis voilà et la page
sera tournée mais ici et d'expliquer
l'inexplicable
s'il excuser l'inexcusable et en
l'occurrence je pense que ça ne sert à
rien d'essayer d'avoir raison lorsque
tout le monde vous dit vous avez tort et
malheureusement la situation elle est là
c'est dommage et c'est dommage pour tous
ceux qui travaillent difficilement je
pense dans nos dans nos établissements
scolaires qui ont une rentrée compliquée
parce que il est vrai que les protocoles
qui ont été imposées sont pas toujours
compréhensible il est vrai qu'il ya eu
beaucoup d'hésitations du gouvernement
vous parliez des masques on parle aussi
de l'ensemble des mesures qui ont été
prises qui parfois ont donné le
sentiment qu'ils avaient des
allers-retours et 12 a fait que en plus
de ça vous avez un ministre qui donne le
sentiment d'être un peu en distance yale
alors il est vrai qu au télétravail est
important mais là c'est un distant ciel
qui en dehors de nos frontières et donc
de ce fait la choque une bonne partie de
la population bien sûr qu' il n'y a pas
de quoi en faire un livre est un roman
mais les symboles ça compte et vous le
savez très bien parce que lorsque le
président de la république fait des
manifestations à forte teneur symbolique
vous êtes les premiers à applaudir et
est donc le fêtait ses clara bon
malheureusement pour lui et pour
l'ensemble des personnels de l'éducation
nationale il a fait une erreur il faut
l'admettre et je pense que si ce soir il
intervient sur une chaîne de télévision
c'est sans doute aussi parce qu'il a le
sentiment que l'erreur et est là et
qu'il faut essayer de la corriger on va
écouter justement les réactions de
yannick jadot suivi de matt hill
panneaux à la france insoumise qui
demandent le départ du ministre
au lieu de préparer avec les enseignants
et les parents d'élèves une rentrée sous
qu'ovide le ministre organisé un coup
médiatique les pieds dans le sable ce
niveau de mépris et d'irresponsabilité
n'est pas acceptable je demande de
nouveau la démission de jean michel
blanquer trop c'est trop jean michel
blanquer doit démissionner gars et on
dissocier c'est pas devenu un petit peu
tout de même le bouc émissaire du
gouvernement on a vu un jean michel
blanquer s'affronter un petit peu avec
le ministre de la santé après tout il a
certainement eu l'aval de sa hiérarchie
pour partir en vacances jean michel
blanquer
tout lui tombe dessus
si vous voulez les problèmes internes au
gouvernement et de qui finalement arrive
à tirer la couverture davantage à lui ne
m'intéresse pas vraiment et saas je
laisse ça plutôt au gouvernement et à la
gestion finalement de ses équipes du du
président de la république mais il faut
bien retenir une chose c'est que si les
vacances de jean michel blanquer air ont
fait couler tant d'encre aujourd'hui et
si on en parle encore ce soir sur votre
plateau c'est tout simplement parce que
les protocoles de rentrée scolaire ars a
été un véritable fiasco qu'on a eu en
moins d'une semaine trois protocoles
différents qui se sont enchaînés que ça
a été un calvaire est un enfer aussi
bien je le répète pour les élèves que
pour les professeurs que pour les
parents d'élèves qui n'arrivait plus à
s'y retrouver que tout ça a été fait
comme d'habitude depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire de façon très arbitraire
très verticale de la part de l'état sans
aucune concertation des principaux
intéressés à savoir les acteurs locaux
dans seulement de l'enseignement mais
aussi je pense à tous ces élus locaux à
tous ce maillage associatif qui pourtant
ont été très bienveillant et très utile
notamment lors du tout premier
confinement quand il s'agissait de venir
on est de répondre aux manquements de
l'état sur un certain nombre de
dispositions comme notamment la mise en
place à damas donc si vous voulez encore
une fois c'est l'échec d'abord de la
politique et du protocole de rentrée de
jean michel blanquer qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il y à polémique en effet
la polémique s'est pas tu l'as pas
l'alpha et l'oméga d'un débat politique
ni l'alpha et l'oméga d'un engagement
politique bien entendu mais ça traduit
quand même un malaise et ce malaise
c'est ce fossé considérable qu'il y as
entre la tête de l'état d'un côté et le
peuple de l'autre je pense que l'un ne
comprend plus l'autre et j'espère qu
évidemment ça se traduira par un
réassort ou du mois sursaut politique et
électoral dans le calme des élections
présidentielles cabaret ça c'est vrai
que c'est un reproche qui est souvent
fait au delà de cette cette polémique
qui est peut être vaine aux yeux de
certains ce côté hors sol des manières
macro lui même de son gouvernement par
rapport aux vraies préoccupations des
français je pense que le côté leurs
soldes c'est de s'occuper de sujets
polémiques qui s'effiloche qui
n'intéresse pas les français
l'estimé qui faisait bien son travail
peut-être qu'on l'attaquerait pas à ce
point sur peut-être cette goutte d'eau
vous m'avez dit emmanuel macron et jean
michel drucker je pense que les deux
font extrêmement bien leur travail
vraiment sincèrement jean michel
blanquer ça fait cinq ans qu'il est là
c'est le ministre de l'éducation qui est
resté le plus longtemps emmanuel macron
on a traversé une crise il a dirigé
notre pays est tenu le gouvernail chaque
fois qu'il ya eu un coup de riz
donc non ce que ce que je crois surtout
c'est que imaginons qu'on ait écouté
madame pécresse et qu'on est réouvert
les écoles une semaine après la
désorganisation dans les familles de sur
les gens qui il ya eu quand même 70 %
des élèves il ya 30 % d'élèves manquant
bien 70% ont pensé 70% alors dans ces
cas-là y a plus d'école comment font les
parents c'est difficile je vous entends
bien sûr les masques sur les marche
avant marche arrière assez faible sur
mais c'est difficile c'est difficile de
à la fois satisfaire et à la fois
contraindre par des mesures sanitaires
c'est très compliqué
donc c'est normal que les gens ne soient
pas très satisfait et imaginons rattrape
emmanuel macron à trois mois de la
présidentielle on voit une légère baisse
dans les sondages mais s'il réussit à
japon qui aurait pu rattraper emmanuel
macron c'est justement ne pas
s'impliquer à ce point dans ces mesures
sanitaires et dans cette crise ça ça
aurait pu le rattraper maintenant je
crois que personne je pense que personne
ne peut revendiquer le fait de pouvoir
faire mieux que peut-être régal n'est
pas mieux on fait les choses en période
de pandémie une pandémie c'est pas une
épidémie donc c'est c'est vraiment
l'essence même de la chose évidemment
c'est pas facile évidemment c'est facile
pour personne évidemment c'est pas
facile pour les élèves qui rentrent qui
voient leurs petits camarades qui porte
à maze qui porte une masque qui
évidemment rien n'est simple mais est ce
que vous croyez que c'est plus simple
que de dire on reporte d'une semaine et
d'ailleurs si jamais on avait reporté
d'une semaine et que on aurait dit mais
évidemment emmanuel blanc terre
jean michel blanquer pardon
c'est drôle comme lapsus et mme jean
michel blanquer et ivy ça alors
évidemment ça la range de reporter d'une
semaine eh bien non vous voyez on tient
les on tient les rênes et je crois
qu'elles sont bien tenues franck
louvrier
conseiller de sur une question gilles
ajoutent ils et elles sont aussi des
heures voilà qu'on a pu faire mais
c'était il ya 15 ans mais au-delà de ça
qu'on se connaît on est face à une
situation assez simple en fin de compte
c'est que
le ministre de l'éducation nationale est
un joker au début du gouvernement il en
est devenu là je dirais un roddick a et
c'est la traduction d'un gouvernement et
d'un exécutif épuisés qu'ils s'en doute
n'a plus la réalité du contact avec ce
qui se passe dans le pays et pour réagir
comme ça je pense qu'à un moment donné
bon voilà c'est ce qui fait que la
démocratie et les scènes va aller vers
le changement et le changement ça va
être bien sûr de nouvelles équipes et
j'espère aussi une nouvelle majorité
mais c'est ça en fin de compte c'est que
on le voit bien sur des décisions aussi
majeur sur des prises de position aussi
symbolique on fait des erreurs après
cinq ans de responsabilités
donc ça prouve quand même que tout ça
fait que ça demande beaucoup de
changements je voudrais vous montrer un
sondage
73 % des sondés trouvent le climat
ennuyeux parce qu'on ne parle pas des
vraies préoccupations
des français qui a étendu soucier ça
vous l'expliquez comment parce que c'est
vrai que le coc vide on ne parle que de
ça là on en fait l'expérience
malheureusement on essaye de parler
d'autre chose sûre sur cette chaîne
aussi mais
certains candidats deviennent presque
transparent par moments vous le vous le
déplorez au rassemblement national vous
en avez cette même lecture
plus que la transparence des candidats
masse qui m'inquiète et vous avez
parfaitement raison de le souligner ce
soir c'est l'absence d'un véritable
débat présidentiel une véritable
campagne présidentielle on al'impression
dire c'est quand même un sacré mais on
est un peu plus de 80 jours du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle en
temps normal
c'est le sujet de l'élection au cul et
sature l'ensemble des médias et on ne
parle que de ça et de tous les sujets
qui préoccupent les français comme par
exemple le pouvoir d'achat avec encore
les prix du carburants qui ont atteint
un sommet jamais égalée par un vent là à
80 jours la dernière fois que je
regardais la télé le bandeau qui avait
marqué c'était olivier rey olivier vers
en positif au co vide désolé mais
l'actualité à 80 jours de l'élection
mère de toutes les élections de
l'élection présidentielle qui fixe
finalement quel avenir en décident pour
notre pays pendant cinq ans et bien de
se dire que tout ça c'est secondaire par
rapport à la contamination d'un ministre
à une maladie que finalement avec
laquelle on est obligé est contraint de
vivre maintenant et on s'est habitué à
vivre depuis deux ans bien oui
évidemment le débat présidentiel n'est
pas là mais encore possible de se
demander pourquoi la raison elle est
très simple il fallait la chercher du
côté de l'elysée parce que c'est qui qui
est stérile justement cette crise
sanitaire c'est qu'il est de l'huile sur
le feu en disant qu'ils emmerdent les
français si le président de la
république parce que le président de la
république a tout intérêt à fuir le
débat de la campagne présidentielle à
fuir les allées les répondants ce
qu'attend d'eux les français sont un
grand nombre de sujets qui les
préoccupent comme le pouvoir d'achat la
sécurité l'immigration le
communautarisme pour mieux finalement se
draper de ces deux sets ce déguisement
un peu confortable et chevalier blanc de
celui qui vous protège face à un virus
qui aujourd'hui ne sont quasiment plus
je pense que c'est terriblement
dangereuse qui est en train de se passer
que ça va pousser énormément de français
vers l'abstention nous nous serons là
sur le terrain nous lançons des
décennies dernier nous avons lancé des
grandes campagnes de terrain sur le
marché pour aller à la rencontre des
français et leur dire de ne pas se faire
voler cette élection par la crise
sanitaire il faut que eux se sont
saisies s'il faut qu'ils fassent
l'élection il faut qu'ils aillent voter
s'ils tombent dans le piège de
l'abstention on ne s'en sortira pas et
pierre cabaret vous avez ce sentiment
aussi que parfois la majorité dont vous
faites partie et ont pas reculer
l'exécutif
voilà instruments les instrumentalisent
un petit peu cette crise sanitaire parce
que c'est vrai qu'elle occupe le terrain
et élections approchent on voit moins
peut-être les autres il a bien sûr tout
le monde en parle donc évidemment que
des gens on parle de sujets importants
quand on parle mais je voudrais rebondir
sur l'intérêt du président que de se
déclarer candidat oui ce serait
l'intérêt du président que de se
déclarer candidat aujourd'hui sûrement
mais sa fonction et sa mission
je suis désolé mais aujourd'hui on a
intérêt à avoir un président qui
gouverne et qui se déclarent le plus
tard possible pour pouvoir gouverner le
plus longtemps possible dès qu'il sera
déclaré candidat il ne pourra plus que
difficilement gouverner on est bien
d'accord difficiles vent de de faire des
contraintes 1 parce que ce sont des
contraintes que de porter un masque que
demander des écoliers de le faire donc
aujourd'hui l'intérêt du président son
intérêt pour son élection sa réélection
s'il est candidat c'est de se déclarer
candidat mais l'intérêt de la france et
l'intérêt supérieur de la france c'est
justement d'avoir un président qu'il
gouverne et le plus longtemps possible
voyez
sortiront c'est très clair c'est que
l'exécutif joue avec le feu c'est à dire
qu'à force de essayé de lancer certains
débats sans vouloir rentrer à
l'intérieur de ces débats on l'a vu sur
l'intervention du chef de l'état dans le
parisien on l'a vu sur d'autres débats
ou en fin de compte le gouvernement est
dans une stratégie de l'évitement c'est
à dire que il essaye de faire monter les
extrêmes pour pouvoir essayer de miser
sur un deuxième tour face à des extrêmes
et donc de ce fait la joue
la provocation sans vouloir rentrer sur
le fond du débat vous savez je pense que
le principal responsable de tout ça bien
sûr c'est le chef de l'état c'est lui
qui ne souhaite pas mettre les mains
dans le cambouis du débat et c'est vrai
que alors que normalement il devrait
être candidat aujourd'hui que quasiment
toutes les représentations politiques
qui ont un candidat le fait est même
plusieurs parfois le fait s et que lui
n'en a pas et c'est la majorité sortante
et c'est là où je pense que c'est une
responsabilité directe et personnelle du
chef de l'état dans dans la pauvreté du
débat merci franck louvrier merci
également à gaëtan du sausset et pierre
cabana d'avoir été avec nous en direct à
sur ce plateau